عمل غير مالوف يكشف عنه الفنان والناشط
الصيني اي وي وي في احدث مشروعاته
المعروضه بمتحف التصميم في لندن العمل
عباره عن اعاده صنع لوحه زنابق الماء
الشهيره لكلود موني لكنها مصنوعه في
الواقع من 650 الفا من مكعبات الليغو
باثنين وعشرين لونا مختلفا
بدات في السنوات الاخيره في استخدام قطع
الليغو لتنفيذ رسالتي لذا فهي ايضا
ذكرياتي مع والدي التي درس الفن في باريس
في العشرينيات من القرن الماضي وبعد ذلك
نفيت انا وهو هناك باب اسود خلفي ادمجته
في عمل موني زنابق الماء لان منيف فنان
احبه والدي اذا هذا حقا جزء من الذاكره
تغلب على اعمال قضايا سياسيه وانسانيه
راهنه يلخصها في جملته الشهيره كل شيء فن
كل شيء سياسه كما شكلت حياته الشخصيه
موضوعا في عدد من اعماله لا سيما تجربه
السجن والترحيل من بلاده بسبب مواقفه
المعارضه لسلطات الصينيه
منذ سنين لكني لا اشعر بالاختلاف لانه حتى
داخل الصين فانا شخص بعيد وكان جيل والدي
نفي من قبل الحكومه الصينيه داخل بلدنا
لذا فان العيش خارج ما بداخلنا لا يؤثر
فيا كثيرا حقا
يستخدم اي المقيم حاليا في البرتغال
مجموعه من المواد في التركيبات والاعمال
الفنيه التي يقدمها كالفخار والخشب
والخزفي وحتى الافلام والتصوير
الفوتوغرافي واخيرا
مكعبات ليغو ويعد العمل الفني بعنوان
زنابق الماء رقم واحد لافتا للنظر في معرض
اي الجديد بمتحف التصميم في لندن والمعرض
الذي يركز على التصميم والهندسه المعماريه
هو الاكبر في بريطانيا للفنان الصيني منذ
ثمان سنوات